un minuto de silencio a las 60 8 de la
tarde es la hora exacta del devastador
estallido en el puerto de beirut hace
ahora un mes cuando el cielo de la
capital de líbano se cubrió de humo y el
caos se apoderó de las calles de las
sirenas de las ambulancias y los gritos
de auxilio de los libaneses para para
textil uso en mi vida cambió
drásticamente porque ahora estoy
regresando a mi casa y no tiene techo ni
dormitorio la casa está vacía no se está
lloviendo encima el salón está dañado no
queda nada
no te imaginas cuántas promesas hemos
recibido la gente viene a tomar fotos de
la destrucción prometiendo arreglarla
pero se van y no vuelven nunca
el reguero de destrucción que provocó la
explosión de las 2.700 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio almacenadas desde hace
6 años y de forma insegura en el puerto
se aprecian las fachadas de sus barrios
mientras que los equipos de rescate
continúan con la búsqueda de vida bajo
los escombros al menos 191 personas
fallecieron 86 mil heridos y 300.000
libaneses se quedaron sin hogar
la colosal explosión avivó también la
rabia de los ciudadanos contra sus
gobernantes pero a la mano
no hay esperanza ni siquiera un 1% a
menos que recibamos ayuda del extranjero
directamente a los ciudadanos sino a
nuestros políticos que nos ayuden
directamente ya sea con fondos o
materiales me lo da
ubermedia de la hable la tragedia del
puerto aceleró la precaria situación que
atraviesa el líbano meses de protestas
sociales el rechazo hacia un sistema
político acusado de corrupto e
ineficiente una economía devastada y
agravada con la pandemia que deja a
miles de libaneses entre la desesperanza
y la reconstrucción